dear ladies and gentlemen colleagues and
friends
on world cancer day we all have a
personal story to tell
about family
friends
or about ourselves
a story of struggle pain and resilience
today we're joined by two survivors
it surtot from the european network of
gynecological cancer
and christiana montpur cnn's chief
international anchor
we will hear their testimonials
and their powerful call for prevention
early diagnosis
and equal access to care
a very warm welcome from my side
every story is different
but in every story of cancer there is a
call to action
and that is why we made the fight
against cancer a priority of this
commission
and one year ago today
we launched europe's beating cancer plan
a plan for prevention more research and
better care
now time to look at the progress made so
far and of course at the next steps
ahead
since last year we have begun creating
comprehensive cancer centers and
networks in each member state
by 2025
they will all be linked in the european
network of cancer centers
its goal will be to level up cancer care
across member states
and to improve patient mobility
because everyone in our european union
should get the cancer treatment they
need
especially for rare or complex
conditions
this is our goal
and we will not let up until we have
achieved it
access to high quality care is even more
a priority today
for the fight against cancer the
pandemic was a setback
an estimated 100 million cancer
screening tests
were not performed
up to one in two people with cancer
symptoms
were not urgently referred to diagnosis
this means
that an estimated one million cancer
cases
could right now be undiagnosed in
europe and among patients who know they
have cancer
one in five are still not receiving the
surgical or chemotherapy treatment
they urgently need
this is an incentive for us to make
rapid progress
together with our member states we work
hard to reduce the backlog of cancer
diagnosis and treatment
because these are not just numbers
we're talking about those we love
and about our own health
in moving beyond the pandemic we need to
double down on prevention
so today we are also announcing two new
flagship actions
first on cervical cancer
today we're setting the goal to
vaccinate 90 percent of girls in the
european union by 2030 against human
papilloma virus
and we will significantly increase the
vaccination of boys
we will support member states with funds
from the eu for health program and other
instruments
but we will also work with civil
society it is crucial that we spread the
word
hpv is a serious risk but we have a
solution
and without hpv
we have a chance to eliminate cervical
cancer
this would be an important milestone
it's within our reach
so let's move
the second flagship action is the cancer
inequality registry
because in this fight it is not only
stamina that counts
but also fairness
it will identify trends disparities and
inequalities between member states and
regions so we can better target our
support
it is just not right
that a woman living in one corner of
europe
has a far higher chance of getting
cervical or breast cancer
than if she lived elsewhere in europe
so today the commission has launched the
first stage of the registry
the data tool
and by the end of this year we will
publish the first country performance
reports
of the u-27 plus norway and iceland
this performance data will be available
to all and inform the priorities of next
year's forum
ladies and gentlemen in just one year we
have made significant progress despite
headwind
cancer is a personal story for all of us
i would like to join icho and christian
for calling for prevention early
diagnosis and equal access to care
this is the heart of europe's beating
cancer plan
and with your support
we can realize our goals
thank you so much